foreign
[Music]
so how was Vegas
um please oh tell me about the best
place on Earth yeah it was like 48 Hours
of just straight gambling
I don't know if I could do that again
it's a lot so are you down are you up
um well I lost a lot on poker okay a
thousand on poker but there was a point
I was up 600. let me set the context
folks I I ran out to Vegas for a quick
trip with some friends and I was
enlisted in the academy
of a Siva slot develop um the
development okay the development uh tier
okay Siva slot Academy Siva slot school
yeah we're playing slots and I'm going
up I'm going down and then
um
you know I I'm
okay I'm trying to like remember so we
kind of I go up a couple hundred I'm
cool and at this point I'm thinking I
made 200 bucks I might just tap here
and see if it goes nah you gotta you
gotta try to you gotta try yeah yeah so
I went to the high limit slot room
and
he changed the denomination for me
so I was looking at you know it's like
play 160 play whatever and it says play
750 and I'm thinking seven dollars fifty
cents yeah I just played with six dollar
spins so I'm thinking oh I'll play the
7.50 because that's pretty you know
that's up there yeah I've not done that
before I smack it 75 gone and see if it
goes no dude I changed it to 10 cents
and I went oh
oh my God oops
75 bucks on one spin
I bet it I bet that spin felt [__]
good
I bet that was this is how it felt
it's like a gourmet dinner no
that you just like on in in 10 seconds
yeah but it's like lit on fire it's like
a gourmet dinner if I woke up and
someone told me I ate it yeah exactly no
you had the Flaming no it's like you
wake up and it's like on you like
breakfast in bed yeah and then someone
comes and just takes it away yeah like
wait no yeah you can smell it on the way
out you know
yeah so then after that I was like I
think I'm good and he's like no no no
keep going
so I play on the high limit slot I go
back up like another 100 bucks and now I
think I'm up 300 or something I'm
thinking all right I'm this is it this
is it for me you know and it made me
think dude these old people that are
just like chain smoking smacking in
terms of their appetite for adrenaline
and difficult things they could probably
Drive Formula One yeah probably they
could probably go to war they could
fight like because they're like
desensitized oh completely yeah yeah
yeah yeah because you have these
machines that are like designed to hit
all of the pleasure centers in your
brain yeah and they've just been doing
that for so long it's like going on
4chan for your entire life yeah yeah
like they're probably phased by nothing
yeah yeah I think you could probably get
one of those people to shoot someone and
they wouldn't yeah yeah yeah you know
they probably hear the bonus reel when
they fired yeah boom
yeah that person dies
so I get a hand pay for this right yeah
yeah yeah that was a stupendous right
stupendous kill this is stupendous kill
right did you ever try
yeah I kind of look around yeah and then
push it up
yeah so on the security camera's like
what the [__] is this guy doing oh
they're like you slot scraping get them
out of here everyone knows get them out
it actually works it works we're kind of
waffling about and then we land on it's
like fire something's got a little
monkey on it you know I look at it and
I'm thinking Hmm
so here here became my strategy
I would walk around looking at slot
machines and I would look for slot
machines with an ashtray with a bunch of
cigarette butts okay and I would tell
Siva that looks like pain I'm looking
for pain okay because what I Envision is
someone
and they bomb out and they just left all
the bad spins yeah so
I'm playing the little fire connect
whatever it's called I'm playing a
little monkey
I'm not doing too hot
but then I see this lady next to me and
she's got just she's got sad written all
over
um so the lady gets up
and
some guys walk over to service the
machine next to me and I get up and I go
to the sad lady slot
and then another service guy yeah that's
the one another service guy walks up and
they start servicing all three of the
machines next to me except mine so I'm
thinking there's like some
some [__] Voodoo going on right now
hey what are you thinking they're gonna
it's gonna let me win
why because it wants to distract from
the machines looking down so I have this
conspiracy that it's all about Optics
okay you know yeah yeah right were they
all the same game yeah so maybe the
service guys were like these are winning
too much
it could be that too but we can't
service the one he's on because he's
playing on it could be that too right
yeah they're just they're like we need
to give him a little something so he
leaves so before it pays him real big
yeah you're right right so
I'm cruising down the order now okay now
on this fire link I'm probably got
200 bucks left so I'm 800 down okay this
is the most I've been down on a slot
machine right I think there's one other
time I've been this down
and then it's I'm I'm spinning I'm
spinning I'm like dude this has gotta
hit I'm gonna puke
and lo and behold it hits see that's all
you got to do is just ask for it yeah
yeah please hit or I'm gonna puke but
here's the thing that I was doing
because as soon as it started hitting I
was thinking it's not going to pay me
[__] it took all my money and that's
just where it's gonna end so I tell
Steve I'm like I'm gonna hype this up so
I got like I want like 20 bucks
on the first reel and I just scream I'm
like oh
people are like okay let me stop let me
stop and then it starts hitting for real
and then I'm like oh [__]
and then when it finally wraps I got a
hand pay for 1500 bucks yeah that's so
sick so I got the 500 and
they had to you know the lady had to
come over and take my social security
number and my ID and how to get the hand
pay and I got a tax form now wow I got
it I got it when does that become a
thing after 1200 damn yeah I played some
more slots the next day and I lost I'm
like [__] this I'll take my 300 bucks
and I want and I'll leave then I go play
poker
and then I go back up 200 bucks I think
one of these guys is uh he's he's
joshing people a little bit you know he
seems willing to bet a lot of money just
on like if if he gets like Ace Jack or
Ace Queen he'll bet a lot of money so I
chase him down I I won big on him so
that was awesome so then I'm feeling
like
i'm the poker God
uh and I've you know then I go played
another table and I completely forget
that uh poker is a game of odds and this
old dude next to me was
annihilating the table how so he could
play any hand and he would [__] own
you I'm like Jesus [__] Christ man
you're on fire and he looks at me he's
like
and so I got into it with him a good six
hundred dollars
because I was I just made it a point I'm
like I'm gonna get this guy I'm a
[__] every time every time I chased
him bodied me wow and then my final like
300 400 bucks I was just on tilt because
being on tilt just mean like you're like
just yeah you're kind of like rapist
yeah yeah okay you're just you're like
yeah six seven suited and there's a
there's a king and a jack on the board
yeah I'm a [__] crush this because
you're like on the last bit of your
stack kind of and like in perspective to
what you had before you're like ah this
[__] means nothing anymore because I
lost the bulk of it it's that and then
it's also like
I'm a piece of [__] loser
that's true yeah I'm a [__] nobody I
think that's mostly what it is yeah yeah